on fait juste du sans alcool puis on est
fier de le faire
c'est de plus en plus populaire il y a
de plus en plus de demandes
on écrit une mode
personne n'aurait cru à ça la croissance
est commun infinie
ou juste avant les fêtes la
microbrasserie la gabière a lancé non
pas une mais quatre bières sans alcool
un succès instantané on a fait quand
même beaucoup d'avance pour être prêt à
se faire à la demande finalement mais ça
sort ça sort
de sans alcool à toutes les bâches pour
mettre ces nouveaux produits sur le
marché l'entreprise a passé un an en
recherche et développement on voulait
vraiment faire une bière qu'on
désalcoolise on retire l'eau et l'alcool
on remet l'eau sans alcool ton
reconstitue la bière si on veut avant
d'embrasser Sébastien la Gagnaire
n'était pas un grand amateur des bières
sans alcool les produits je voulais
goûter pour le contrôle qualité puis de
deux on dirait que j'ai du plaisir à les
voir autant qu'une bière normale
souvent dans une soirée entre une bière
normale une bière sans alcool un marché
qui est en pleine ébullition en 2015 15
millions de litres de bière sans alcool
ont été vendus au Canada une quantité
qui a plus que quadruplé l'an dernier
pour atteindre près de 68 millions de
litres ou si vous préférez 8 millions de
caisse de 24 ce qui représente 3% de
toute la bière vendu au pays puis on en
a toute dernière qui est une édition
limitée pour le mois sans alcool il y a
environ trois ans Yann carrière et ses
amis ont lancé bière sans alcool une
autre prise dont le nom laisse peu de
doute sur sa spécialité on pensait que
ça serait juste un projet de soirée fin
de semaine pour s'offrir une belle
option sans alcool on a commencé avec
deux produits puis aujourd'hui
voyez-vous on a 7 produits dans plus de
1200 points de vente au Québec en
seulement deux ans et demi puis on
commence à développer le reste du Canada
donc on a à peu près 300 points de vente
dans le reste du Canada pour l'instant
selon lui la perception des boissons
sans alcool a beaucoup évolué ce qui
contribue à leur popularité quand
arriver dans un soirée ou quelque chose
avec un alcool les gens pensaient que tu
devais boire du sans alcool parce que tu
avais un problème c'était la solution
quelque chose tandis qu'aujourd'hui les
gens il y a pas d'obligation à vendre
sans alcool ils vont parce qu'il y aime
ce segment de produit là
le marché des breuvages sans alcool et
de plus en plus diversifiée au cours des
dernières années les spiritueux se sont
ajoutés à l'offre c'est le jean esprit
de London qui est un jean sans alcool
c'est notre premier et qu'on a sorti au
tout début il y a 3 ans en plus de gin
la distillerie Noroy en bouteille du
rhum un apéritivo un whisky et une
tequila sans alcool et c'est sans
compter les cocktails prête à boire en
2020 elle a aussi lancé la marque
atypique devenu tellement populaire que
le géant américain des boissons gazeuses
querides docteur Pepper en a fait
l'acquisition des produits qui se sont
accaparés une grande part des ventes de
l'entreprise en quelques années à peine
c'est une porte de 25% 25% de chiffre
d'affaires approximatif c'est quand même
le produit par contre au niveau de
l'exportation qu'un très grand intérêt
parce que pas beaucoup de joueurs à
marcher la distillerie est en train
d'agrandir ses installations ici c'est
une seule imaginer parce qu'on est en
construction mais ça va être la salle
des mélanges et les produits sans alcool
n'y sont pas pour rien
ça va vraiment être la section boutique
ici puis je la gamme maison neuve
Marilou la pointe est en train
d'aménager ce qui deviendra la première
boutique entièrement dédiée aux produits
sans alcool au Québec elle ouvrira ses
portes en février apéro à zéro n'était
auparavant que tout petit comptoir dans
un espace collaboratif les gens se
déplaçaient de loin des Laurentides de
Joliette il venait vraiment pour venir
pour ici pour les conseils pour les
produits mais on voyait c'est comme des
fois on ouvrait les week-ends c'était
plein là c'est un vin rouge l'entreprise
vend plus de 200 produits sans alcool de
toutes sortes c'est vraiment délicieux
il fait une sélection rigoureuse pour
retenir les meilleurs section 20 et
mousseux là c'est quelque chose qui est
très difficile d'avoir dans son alcool
qui est bon souvent moi je les clients
clients qui viennent me voir me disent
je n'ai jamais trouvé un bon enfin que
justement on fait toutes les défrichage
derrière on teste les produits on teste
aussi avec les clients clientes ici
aujourd'hui je fais un cocktail
gingembre et litchi très simple à faire
spécialiste des cocktails ayant deux
livres à son actif rossymar s'intéresse
aussi aux options sans alcool puis on va
venir secouer vigoureusement pour bien
mélanger nos ingrédients est-ce que tous
les models goûtent le cocktail non parce
que l'alcool est un ingrédient quand
même capital dans un cocktail il faut
vous identifices pour tromper les
papilles gustatives quand on boit de
l'alcool il va avoir une certaine
chaleur à cause de l'éthanol il va avoir
un petit côté piquant donc aller
chercher des ingrédients qui peuvent
nous rappeler cet effet-là donc des
piments du gingembre autre conseil pour
ceux qui veulent tenter l'expérience
c'est pas tous les jeans sans alcool qui
sont convaincants pour moi par contre
dans le cas par exemple je pense des
amaretto sans alcool ou des apéritivaux
sans alcool comme il y a du sucre à
l'intérieur le sucre permet d'avoir une
meilleure concentration des saveurs puis
ça ça fait des des
sont très intéressants à utiliser et
voilà santé